niente di quel giorno
marinate dove hai messo la mia felpa che
ne so della tua stella non l'ho mai
vista tote mai vista e guarda che mi
sono accorto che era usata l'altra sera
l'ho vista pure nelle strade delle tre
amiche
senti perché lo chiede la manna magari
alla lavare magari materbi sta accusando
ingiustamente
ma mai visto la mia felpa una matita le
vale pure tu senti signorina invece di
non fare niente e aiuto di un po pulire
casa è ma non lo vedete che mi sto
rilassando cinque minuti cinque minuti
la mia vita e voglio rilasciare voi non
mi lasciate in pace ma fammi il piacere
lega non fa niente dal mattino alla sera
si deve rilasciare e io cosa dovrei dire
è che sono a schiava della casa mi è mai
visto dormire sul divano basta posta in
un viso molto più voglio andare da
questa casa
pace che silenzio che tranquillità sono
che grida nessuno che fa domande
che mardis cosa mi sono persa per tutti
questi mamma sto morendo di fame
cos'è questo profumino te lo dico io poi
c'è il profumino e tutta la mattina che
la tua mamma cucina solo per te amore
allora ti ho fatto la grecia che ti
piace tanto che ho fatto 500 grammi
perché so che rimangi tante di secondo
c'è il pollo con le patate e se poi hai
ancora fame di scadere polpette al sugo
di ieri poi me lo dici tu sei fan e non
al baio ti amo
[Musica]
cucinare
mi sono dimenticato di fare la spesa
adesso cosa mangio solo mezz'ora di
tempo
tornava con leggera tutto pronto
[Musica]
ma ho trovato questa lettera in buca che
faccia la pro aprila no cosa devi fare
dice che devi pagare 300 euro
guarderà meglio non aprirla comunque
signorino a quella è una bolletta del
gas e ora che tu inizia imparare a si
chiama bolletta
vabbè che la lascio qui così la buggy
ciao vado a studiare allora questo è lo
stipendio dal quale ho già tolto
l'affitto che ho parlato ieri alla
proprietaria di casa il wifi l'ho pagato
basta quindi arrivano e suonato da
pagare alla fornitura di ubriacarsi
ma no no tranquilla stavo solo dando
un'occhiata e consumi di luce e gas
abbiamo io lo faccio direttamente
dall'app i falsi come non ti ho detto e
non un fornitore di luce dai 100 per
cento digitale ma guarda ma è
comodissimo e l'attivazione velocissima
anzi perché è una tv anche tu scusa
praticamente se fai l'attivazione entro
il 31 dicembre con il codice marina 200
a uno sconto fino a 100 euro per 24 mesi
per un contratto di fornitura singola
quindi o luce o gas e uno sconto fino a
200 euro per 24 mesi per un contratto di
fornitura luce più tasse sì ed è anche
incluso servizio aggiuntivo ma green
energy adotta un impianto che ti
permette di utilizzare solo energia 100
per 100 rinnovabile per la fornitura
elettrica della tua casa ti ricordi
quando lo sapevo neanche cosa fosse una
bolletta ma ma oggi pomeriggio
passerebbe a trovarmi un mio amico un
amico che mamma un mio amico non c'è non
lo conosci senti pensi che non sia stata
giovani anche io dai dimmi la verità su
tutti devo dire mai ci frequentiamo da
un po lo sapevo è che pensi protesta
canzone albergo per caso è che puoi
portare i fidanzati a farla porcheria
scordatelo è capito fin quando io vivrò
sotto questo tetto tu in casa non porti
proprio nessun ragazzo come scusa mamma
dove non è andare allora in macchina non
lo so ma qui cioè non facciamo niente di
che ma questa è anche casa mia guarda
meglio fronti risponde va bene allora
sai cosa ti dico che ieri sabato vivere
da sola così non devo rendere conto a
nessuno di chi fra quanto meno è capito
niente mi ha chiamato e mi fa ma se
venisse da te stasera e io tipo ho
iniziato un po la preziosa no
o poi ci hanno detto sì ovviamente a
tifare cioè sono mesi che vi sbava
dietro quel buono atomico mi chiede di
venire a casa mia già non subito già
pensare che fino a qualche mese fa vivo
con i miei non potevo neanche nominarle
ragazze
normale che ha fatto questo grade